As your career progresses, you may be looking to gain a pay rise...
...but there are a few things you need to do in order to secure it.
Taking on extra work is a prudent way to get noticed in the workplace.
Taking on more responsibility and projects will show that you're dedicated to the company...
...and interested in career progression.
Keep a log of any extra work you take on...
...and assure you raise this in meetings to support your case for a pay rise.
Networking, whether it's an industry events or internal company events...
...is definitely worth doing if you're looking for a pay rise.
Heading out to networking events is a great way to meet industry contacts...
...and to find out about new opportunities.
Attending internal networking events is also a great way to build rapport with colleagues...
...and senior members of staff.
The only way you can secure a pay rise is by letting your boss know about your progress...
...and work, and by telling them that you are looking for a salary increase.
Gather together your career portfolio...
...and ensure you arrange regular meeting to keep your boss updated.